it does seem like the machine is kind of
trying to scare everybody you guys know
CNN's resident Dr Sanjay Gupta here's
what he tweeted out yesterday because
schools are starting up he wrote schools
around the country are back in session
just in time for respiratory virus
season what are your back to school
questions when it comes to covid-19 RSV
or flu I'll try to answer as many
questions as possible this Wednesday on
CNN this morning so yes it is the fall
and people do tend to get a little more
sick in the fall because the weather is
changing it's a little cooler in most of
the country and yes kids that are around
each other
back in my day I'm a child of the 80s
you'd go to school somebody might be
sick they might take a day off everybody
would deal with it your teacher might be
sick you'd have a substitute teacher you
didn't close school down you didn't shut
kids out for a year and everything else
a DC area Elementary School Montgomery
County Maryland is reinstating a mask
mandate n95s for third graders over a
few kids testing positive for covet
here's the letter they're coming with
masks for your kids again get ready read
this insanity and then he uh he screen
captures the whole thing right there
guys once again as we referenced
yesterday
masks do not work okay even n95 masks
most likely don't work and even if they
did the damage you are doing especially
to a young person a third grader putting
them in this thing I cannot believe this
is where we're at again but the damage
you're gonna put them like their Bane
at least Bane could breathe through that
day but the damage they can't see their
friends they can't smile they just bow
to the system they become little cogs in
a machine it is just so evil and I
wanted to mention this one we showed you
this one yesterday but just real quick
from Jay battachary over at Stanford
it's not just uh elementary schools in
Maryland it's places like University of
Michigan at the University of Michigan
students testing covid positives must
leave their dorms for five days and live
in the community a hotel room or a
relative's house is okay this cruel
policy is designed to spread covid from
the University into the wild it won't
stop covid from spreading it makes no
sense as I talked about yesterday if you
have a kid at a college who's got
coveted let him spread it with a bunch
of young healthy people and maybe
they'll have the sniffles for a little
bit like they would with the flu you
don't send them to Grandma's house
you morons
[Music]